SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLEY. DODD DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MINH NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. RATH. RUBIO SATO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS. IF YOU CAN RETURN TO
OUR DESKS, PLEASE. IF WE CAN
RETURN TO OUR DESK WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE ROW IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE
RISE. WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
DURAZO, AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. LOVING CREATOR,
YOU HAVE BEEN OUR GOD IN THE
PAST, LEADING US FROM CAPTIVITY
TO FREEDOM. YOU ARE THE SPIRIT
WE ADMIRE AND WORSHIP NOW
BENEATH THIS COLOSSAL CREATION
AROUND US. BUT MOSTLY YOU ARE
THE GOD OF MANY NAMES AND
INFINITE MYSTERY WHO DRAWS US
TOWARD A WORLD OF JUSTICE AND
LOVE AND TOWARD HOPE, TOWARD
CREATIVITY AND ENERGETIC LIFE.
WE THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU PROMISE
AS YOU REASSURE US OF YOUR
CARING. SPEAK TO THE SILENT
EXPECTATIONS OF OUR HEARTS. YOU
ARE OUR GOD AND WE SEEK TO BE
YOUR HANDS AND FEET AND HEART.
AMEN MEMBERS AND GUESTS, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE. THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON. COLLEAGUES STARTING
OFF WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
, I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE FORMER
SENATOR DENISE DUCHESNE, WHO IS
WITH US HERE IN THE BACK OF THE.
WELCOME BACK, SENATOR.
IF ANY MEMBERS WOULD LIKE A
PHOTO. MEMBERS, PLEASE JOIN THE
FORMER SENATOR IN THE BACK. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PHOTO.
COLLEAGUES, IF WE'RE DONE SAYING
HELLO TO THE SENATOR, IF WE CAN
RETURN BACK TO OUR DESK. IF WE'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS.
IF WE CAN TAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR,
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
BUSINESS. VERSION TWO IS BETTER
THAN VERSION ONE. YES ALL RIGHT,
COLLEAGUES. MOVING ON TO OUR
SECOND PRESENTATION. UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE MAJORITY
LEADER. COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD
MOVE OUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR, THE MAJORITY LEADER WILL
HAVE A SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I'D JUST LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR INCREDIBLE
HOMETOWN, LONG BEACH MAYOR REX
RICHARDSON, WHO IS HERE WITH
VICE MAYOR CINDY ALLEN, AS WELL
AS COUNCIL MEMBERS ROBERTO
URANGA AND MEGAN KERR. PLEASE
GIVE THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
WELCOME, TEAM LONG BEACH. OUR
THIRD AND FINAL PRESENTATION OF
THE DAY. COLLEAGUES, IS GOING TO
BE SENATOR ALLEN, ARE YOU
PREPARED? YES. SENATOR ALLEN,
FROM YOUR DESK. WELL, THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. FOLKS, WE'VE
GOT THE PRIVILEGE THIS AFTERNOON
TO WELCOME THE WONDERFUL
LEADERSHIP TORRANCE CLASS THAT'S
HERE ALL THE WAY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. NICE TO SEE YOU GUYS
. LEADERSHIP TORRANCE IS A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM, AND I'VE HAD
THE CHANCE TO MEET AND WORK WITH
THEM A NUMBER OF TIMES OVER THE
YEARS. IT'S ORGANIZED BY THE
TORRANCE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
DOWN IN THE SOUTH BAY IN LOS
ANGELES, AND IT BRINGS TOGETHER
ENGAGED BUSINESS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS FROM AROUND THE SOUTH
BAY TO COLLABORATE AND LEARN
FROM ONE ANOTHER. AND IT'S ALL
ABOUT TRYING TO CREATE COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS THAT ALLOW EMERGING
LEADERS IN TOWN TO EFFECTIVELY
PLAY A ROLE IN SHAPING AND
IMPROVING THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY THEY, THEY THEY COME UP
EVERY YEAR TO SACRAMENTO TO
LEARN ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
GET A BETTER INSIGHT INTO THE
WORKINGS OF STATE GOVERNMENT. SO
THEY'VE GOT WE'VE GOT 16 MEMBERS
FROM LEADERSHIP TORRANCE WHO ARE
UP HERE, AND I JUST WOULD LIKE
US TO GIVE A VERY WARM SENATE
WELCOME TO OUR FRIENDS FROM
LEADERSHIP. TORRANCE POINT OF
PRIVILEGE. I HAVE A PREVIOUS
COLLEAGUE UP THERE. WELCOME,
WELCOME, COLLEAGUES. WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. NOW
MOVING ON TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNALS
JOURNALS FOR APRIL FIRST, 2024
THROUGH APRIL 4TH, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. SENATOR WIENER,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES,
I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES AS THEY RELATE TO ASSEMBLY
BILL 106. SUCH WILL BE THE SUCH
WILL. SENATOR MILLER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON THIS
MOTION. AB 106 WAS JUST AMENDED,
AND JUST OVER THE WEEKEND, IT IS
204 PAGES. SENATOR MILLER, I DO
WANT TO REMIND THIS BODY,
SENATOR WIENER HAS REQUESTED TO
SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES. THIS
MOTION IS NOT DEBATABLE, I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW EXPLORATORY,
EXPLORATORY, EXPLANATORY
REMARKS. NOT FOR DEBATE, BUT TO
EXPLAIN MY MOTION ON. SINCE THE
ONLY MOTION, IN FRONT OF US IS
TO SUSPEND THE RULES, THERE'S NO
OTHER MOTION ELIGIBLE AT THE
MOMENT. I RESPECT. I REQUEST
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE. COLLEAGUES,
COULD YOU GIVE US A MINUTE OR
TWO?
SENATOR NILO, PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR BRIEF COMMENTS. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. JUST
SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT THIS
MEANS THAT THIS BILL WILL BE
TAKEN UP ON THURSDAY RATHER THAN
MONDAY. THAT IS FOUR DAYS THAT
THE PUBLIC AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE TIME TO REVIEW SOMETHING
THAT HASN'T EVEN HAD AN ANALYSIS
DRAWN UP YET. I REQUEST A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
COLLEAGUES. SENATOR SENATOR
WIENER IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR NHIÀU IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. MR. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALY. NO. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NO. NHIÀU NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO.
NO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK. NO. NO SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER.
BRADFORD AYE. GROVE ROTH. AYES
30. NOS. SEVEN. THE MOTION
CARRIES COLLEAGUES NOW MOVING ON
TO CONSIDER CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH 21. IN THE SECOND
READING FILE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1075 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1198, WITH AMENDMENTS
1420, WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION 13, WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL 1266,
WITH AMENDMENTS 1175 WITH
AMENDMENTS 12. SECOND READING IS
DEEMED READ. MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS, WE HAVE
ITEMS 23 TO THROUGH 25. SENATOR
GROVE, ARE YOU PREPARED? YES,
MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
NUMBER 23 IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
MONICA ERICKSON, THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN SERVICES.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT, MISS
ERICKSON WAS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION. SHE WAS APPROVED ON
THE AT THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MARCH 20TH ON A50 VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE COLLEAGUES. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE MATTER?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE A. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
NILO. AYE. OTTOBOCK AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. WIENER.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER 24. SENATOR
GROVE, ARE YOU PREPARED AGAIN?
YES, MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. SO
COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM NUMBER 24
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF FERRIS
TRUST, WHO IS THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR STRATEGIC PLANNING
AND EQUITY AND LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT, MISS
TRESKUNOV SERVED AS THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS FOR OVER 20 YEARS,
MOST RECENTLY AS THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF STAFF. SHE WAS
CONFIRMED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
AGAIN ON MARCH 20TH OF A50 VOTE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
COLLEAGUES. A LITTLE LOUD OVER
HERE. IF YOU WANT TO CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATION, IF YOU
COULD TAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN I NILO. AYE OCHOA. BOG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE AYES 38. NO. ZERO.
THAT CONFIRMATION IS APPROVED.
CONTINUING THE SENATOR GROVE
SHOW. SENATOR, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR A FILE ITEM NUMBER 25? NO
MA'AM, I AM NOT MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER 20. YES.
PREPARED ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER 25. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
FILE ITEM NUMBER 25 IS A
CONFIRMATION OF OSCAR GONZALEZ
FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD
AND LAUREN BOLDEN AND REED
MCKELVEY, OR MILANOVICH. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. THEY WERE BOTH
APPROVED ON THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH 20TH WITH A50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DURAZZO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. YES. IN PARTICULAR,
I WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF MR.
OSCAR GONZALEZ JUNIOR. I'VE
KNOWN HIM FOR MANY YEARS. HE AND
HIS PARTNER ARE EXTRAORDINARY
PEOPLE WHO NOT ONLY CARE ABOUT
THE HORSE RACING INDUSTRY, BUT
CARE ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE. SO I STAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR DODD, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
YES. I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR OSCAR GONZALEZ
JUNIOR. HE HAS PERFORMED, YOU
KNOW, AND FRANKLY, THE WHOLE
COMMISSION. WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
HAD LOTS OF ISSUES THERE FOR
MANY YEARS. AND I REALLY THINK
THE IMPROVEMENT THAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH HORSE RACING OVER THE LAST
4 OR 5 YEARS IS A DIRECT RESULT
OF PEOPLE LIKE OSCAR GONZALEZ JR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR GROVE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? JUST TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS, THIS IS A
VERY OUTSTANDING APPOINTMENT
WITH A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITHIN
THE HORSE RACING INDUSTRY. THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY, WITH USDA
AND MANY OTHERS. HE'S VERY
QUALIFIED FOR THE POSITION.
AGAIN, HE WAS APPROVED BY A50
VOTE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE.
ALVARADO GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ I DALLY. AYE. DODD AYE.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. JONES. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD AYE. LEMON. AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR I MEAN
AYE. NEWMAN I WHEN. AYE. NILO
AYE. OCHOA. BOG AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYE
38. NO. ZERO. THE CONFIRMATION
IS APPROVED. COLLEAGUES, WE ARE
NOW IN THE SENATE. THIRD
READING. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
UNDER HERE 43, 52 AND 54 IS
SENATOR WAHAB READY? YES
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1353 BY SENATOR WAHAB. AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES.
SENATOR, YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. SB 1353 WILL ADD TO
THE EXISTING YOUTH BILL OF
RIGHTS THAT YOUTH DETAINED IN
JUVENILE FACILITIES ARE NOT TO
BE DEPRIVED OF MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES. ACCORDING TO A 2017
REVIEW FROM THE US OFFICE OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND DELINQUENCY
PREVENTION, YOUTH WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS WHO ARE INVOLVED
WITH OUR JUSTICE SYSTEMS ARE
MOST MORE LIKELY TO RECIDIVATE.
SB 1353 EMPOWERS INCARCERATED
YOUTH AND PROMOTES
ANTI-RECIDIVISM BY EMPHASIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES IN THE
YOUTH BILL OF RIGHTS, SB 1353 IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. WE ARE
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY,
COLLABORATIVELY WITH CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
ON AMENDMENTS FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
COLLEAGUES, DO WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE
AND THIS ITEM SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLY. DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES
LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA.
BORG. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. RUBIO ACIERTO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBER WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER. TALLY
JONES. NGUYEN NHIÀU. OCHOA. BOGH
ROTH. SUGIARTO. UMBERG AYE. AYE
AYES 32. NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE A FILE
. ITEM NUMBER 52. SENATOR LAIRD,
ARE YOU PREPARED? SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1150 BY
SENATOR LAIRD, AN ACT RELATING
TO MARRIAGE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. SENATE
BILL 1150 WILL UPDATE THE TITLE
OF CHAPTER SEVEN OF DECISION SIX
OF THE FAMILY CODE TO ENSURE
PEOPLE, REGARDLESS OF GENDER
IDENTITY, CAN RESTORE THEIR
FORMER SURNAME FOLLOWING A
DIVORCE. THE CHAPTERS LANGUAGE
WAS UPDATED NEARLY 30 YEARS AGO
TO CONTAIN GENDER SPECIFIC
NEUTRAL LANGUAGE, BUT THE
CHAPTERS TITLE RESTORATION OF
WIFE'S FORMER NAME WAS LEFT
UNCHANGED. THIS IS SIMPLY A
CORRECTION TO ALIGN A CHAPTERS
DATED GENDER SPECIFIC TITLE WITH
ITS GENDER NEUTRAL CODE SECTION
LANGUAGE. THERE WERE NO NO VOTES
IN THE COMMITTEE. Ã BIPARTISAN
YES VOTE. I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DO WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE? SENATOR
TROBO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR WITH THE
WITH THE AUTHOR. TAKE A
QUESTION. SURE, SENATOR, PLEASE
PROCEED. CURIOUS AS TO WHERE
WE'RE REPLACING THE WORD WIFE.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHY NOT THE
WORD SPOUSE, WHICH IS ALSO
GENDER NEUTRAL RATHER THAN A
PARTNER? SENATOR LAIRD, WE'RE
REPLACING IT WITH PARTNER
BECAUSE PARTNER FIT EVERY
SITUATION BETTER THAN THAT. AND
SO WE JUST CHOSE TO DO IT THAT
WAY. SENATOR CHROBOG, YOU'RE
ONCE AGAIN RECOGNIZED. SO I'M
I'M GOING TO LAY OFF THE BILL
TODAY JUST BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE
THAT THE WORD PARTNER ACTUALLY
REFERENCES THE WORD WIFE AS IT
STATES AS IN MARRIAGE. SO I
TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE WORD
SPOUSE IS A BETTER FIT FOR WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO REPLACE AS WIFE,
WHICH MEANS A LEGAL DEFINITION
OF A PARTNERSHIP. SO I'M GOING
TO STAY OFF OF THE BILL. BUT I
TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT THE WORDS
SPOUSE INHERENTLY CONVEYS THE
SAME MEANING AS MARRIAGE AS A
WIFE. BUT IT'S GENDER NEUTRAL.
DO WE HAVE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SENATOR
LAIRD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
FORBID FROM A FOLLICALLY
CHALLENGED PERSON TO SAY, WE'RE
SPLITTING HAIRS, BUT WE ARE
SPLITTING HAIRS, THE WORD THAT
IS HERE WILL DO THE TRICK.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DEL.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
LAIRD. AYE LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE A STERN AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE COLLEAGUES, I KNOW
IT'S MONDAY. I GET IT BACK FROM
THE WEEKEND, BUT IT'S GETTING
TOO LOUD. COLLEAGUES, IF YOU CAN
TAKE OUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR OR RETURN TO OUR SEATS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN. THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BECKER, DALY. GROVE JONES,
NGUYEN. OKUBO ROTH. SATO AYES
32. NØ ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 54.
SENATOR LAIRD, ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THIS ITEM? YES, I AM, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO PRESENT.
SENATOR. WE'VE GOT TO READ IT.
FIRST SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 75 BY SENATOR
LAIRD, RELATIVE TO THE YEAR OF
THE CALIFORNIA GRIZZLY. NOW, YOU
MAY PROCEED. WELL, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION 75, WHICH
DECLARES 2024 AS THE YEAR OF THE
CALIFORNIA GRIZZLY BEAR TO MARK
THE CENTENNIAL OF THE LOSS OF
THIS ICONIC SPECIES IN OUR
STATE, A SENATE RESOLUTION 75 IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
GRIZZLY ALLIANCE, A COALITION OF
RESEARCHERS, TRIBAL LEADERS,
WILDLIFE ADVOCATES, LAND
MANAGERS, AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THE RESOLUTION IS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY NUMEROUS CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
AND MANY TRIBES, INCLUDING THE
YUROK, TULE RIVER, AND TEJON
TRIBES. THE CALIFORNIA GRIZZLY
BEAR IS THE STATE'S MOST
ENDURING SYMBOL. IT IS THE
CENTER OF OUR FLAG AND SEAL,
MORE THAN 800 PLACES AND 100
LANDFORMS ARE NAMED AFTER THE
GRIZZLY. FOR THOUSANDS OF YEARS,
THEY WERE ABUNDANT THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THEY HELD A UNIQUE
SOCIAL, CULTURAL, AND RELIGIOUS
SIGNIFICANCE TO MANY CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES AND HAD A
CRUCIAL ECOLOGICAL ROLE BECAUSE
OF OVERHUNTING AND HABITAT
DESTRUCTION. GRIZZLY BEARS
COMPLETELY DISAPPEARED OVER THE
COURSE OF ONE HUMAN LIFETIME. IT
WAS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SPECIES
LOSS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
THIS YEAR MARKS THE 100TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE LAST CREDIBLE
SIGHTING OF A LIVE WILD GRIZZLY
BEAR IN CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR,
MORE THAN EVER, WE SHOULD
REFLECT ON ITS LOSS AND DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE NO
OTHER NATIVE SPECIES GOES UNDER.
IT GOES EXTINCT, EXTINCT UNDER
OUR WATCH. FOR THESE REASONS, I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SENATE
RESOLUTION 75. THANK YOU
SENATOR. COLLEAGUES ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ISSUE? GRIZZLY BEARS SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN I. NILO. AYE. OCHOA
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. RUBIO AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER JONES
. AYE. ROTH AYES 38. NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NOW.
MOVING ON TO CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS, 74 AND 75. IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1122. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION EIGHT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
FIRST ITEM ON Ã. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER.
BREAKSPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
WHEN I NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BOG
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO
AYE. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK.
AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER. ROTH.
SKINNER AYES 37. NO ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED.
NOW RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. BUT BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I'M GOING TO NEED
EVERYONE BACK AT THEIR DESKS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING OUR
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES. WE WILL
CEASE ALL CONVERSATIONS DURING
OUR JOURNEY IN MEMORIES AND BE
BACK AT OUR DESK. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH SENATOR ATKINS.
MADAM PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DOCTOR
STEVEN L WEBER, WHO IS A FORMER
PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. HE DIED PEACEFULLY
AT HIS HOME ON MARCH 17TH, 2024.
IT WAS HIS 82ND BIRTHDAY. STEVE
WAS BORN IN BOSTON ON SAINT
PATRICK'S DAY IN 1942. AFTER THE
DEATH OF HIS FATHER AT AGE NINE,
THE FAMILY MOVED TO STONY RIDGE,
OHIO, WHERE HE GREW UP. HE
ATTENDED BOWLING GREEN STATE
UNIVERSITY, WHERE HE EARNED A
BACHELOR OF ARTS IN PHILOSOPHY
IN 1964, AND WHILE AT BOWLING
GREEN, HE FELL IN LOVE WITH HIS
FUTURE WIFE, SUSAN KI¾M, AND THE
COUPLE MARRIED IN 1965. STEVE
PURSUED GRADUATE WORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF COLORADO BOULDER
AND EARNED A PHD IN PHILOSOPHY,
PHILOSOPHY, EXCUSE ME FROM NOTRE
DAME IN 1969. HE SERVED AS A
TENURED PROFESSOR OF PHILOSOPHY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF MAINE, AND
THEN MOVED ON TO HOLD
ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MAINE, FAIRFIELD UNIVERSITY, AND
SAINT CLOUD UNIVERSITY. IN 1988,
HE BECAME THE PRESIDENT OF STATE
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK, OSWEGO,
AND IN 1995 HE WAS APPOINTED AS
THE INTERIM PROVOST PROVOST AT
THE ENTIRE 64 CAMPUS OF THE SUNY
SYSTEM. IN JULY OF 1996, HE WAS
SELECTED AS THE SEVENTH
PRESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY, WHERE HE SERVED FOR
15 VERY TRANSFORMATIVE YEARS,
RETIRING IN 2011. DURING HIS
TENURE, THE UNIVERSITY RAISED
ACADEMIC STANDARDS. THEY LED THE
NATION IN IMPROVED GRADUATION
RATES, DIVERSIFIED THE STUDENT
BODY, AND THEY PIONEERED
PROGRAMS TO HELP MILITARY
VETERANS AND FIRST GENERATION
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE CAMPUS
EXPERIENCE AN UNPRECEDENTED
EXPANSION OF FACILITIES,
INCLUDING A NEW SPORTS ARENA, A
TROLLEY STATION, AND NUMEROUS
RESIDENCE HALLS AND ACADEMIC
BUILDINGS. STEVE WAS RENOWNED
FOR HIS COLLABORATIVE LEADERSHIP
STYLE, HIS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT,
AND HIS EFFORTS TO MAKE SDSU A
TOP RESEARCH INSTITUTION. HE WAS
A DRIVING FORCE BEHIND THE
CAMPAIGN FOR SDSU THAT RAISED
$800 MILLION IN DONATIONS OVER
THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS, HE
DONATED $100,000 TO START THE
STEVEN WEBER FUND FOR
EXCELLENCE, AN ENDOWMENT TO
SUPPORT FACULTY IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S COLLEGE OF ARTS AND
LETTERS. AFTER RETIREMENT, HE
MOVED TO MAINE, LATER ON TO
VIRGINIA AND NEW JERSEY, BUT HE
CONTINUED TO SUPPORT SDSU,
VISITING SAN DIEGO OFTEN, AND HE
COULD BE SEEN CHEERING ON THE
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
AZTECS AT SPORTING EVENTS. HE
ACTIVELY CAMPAIGNED FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL 2018 BALLOT MEASURE
TO SELL THE MISSION VALLEY
STADIUM SITE TO SDSU FOR CAMPUS
EXPANSION, INCLUDING
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW STADIUM.
IN 2021, HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALS, AN EXCRUCIATING DISEASE,
AND IN SPITE OF HIS PHYSICAL
DECLINE, HE ALWAYS MAINTAINED A
POSITIVE SPIRIT AND PUBLISHED A
COLLECTION OF INSPIRING ESSAYS,
REFLECTIONS IN THE MIRROR OF
LIFE. JUST LAST YEAR, SUSAN
WEBER, HIS WIFE OF 49 YEARS,
PASSED AWAY IN 2014. STEVE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING COMPANION
STEPHANIE RALPH, HIS SONS MATT
AND RICK, GRANDSONS COLIN AND
AARON, HIS BROTHERS JOHN AND
ROGER. STEVE WAS A TRUE
PHILOSOPHER KNOWN FOR HIS
INTELLECT, HIS ANALYTICAL MIND,
HIS CONTEMPLATIVE NATURE, VISION
AND GRACE, GREAT PATIENCE AND
HONESTY. SO, COLLEAGUES, I WOULD
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY IN
MEMORY OF PRESIDENT STEVEN
WEBER, A REMARKABLE SERVANT
LEADER, A TRUE AZTEC FOR LIFE.
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE ALL
DEEPLY SADDENED, AND WE
BENEFITED FROM HIS CAREER AND
HIS SERVICE. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE LOVELY
WORDS. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO THAT HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
JOURNAL, SENATOR HURTADO, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM PRESIDENT,
MEMBERS, I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF MAYOR OLIVIA
TRUJILLO FROM THE CITY OF ARVIN,
SURROUNDED BY HER THREE LOVING
DAUGHTERS. MAYOR TRUJILLO PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY ON MARCH THIRD.
MAYOR TRUJILLO EXEMPLIFIED WHAT
IT IS TO BE THE DAUGHTER OF THE
VALLEY SEARCHING FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM. OLIVIA, AT THE
AGE OF FIVE, IMMIGRATED WITH HER
FAMILY TO THE CITY OF ARVIN. SHE
WAS THE PROUD DAUGHTER OF
FARMWORKERS. GROWING UP, SHE
HARVESTED FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
IN THE FIELDS OF OUR VALLEY.
OLIVIA EMBODIED THE RESILIENT
SPIRIT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS
A DETERMINED FIGHTER. HER
DEDICATION WAS UNLIKE ANY ANYONE
I KNOW DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER,
SHE RAN FOR CITY OFFICE LEADING
WITH STRENGTH. CANCER DIDN'T
DETER HER. SHE PERSISTED AND
WON. SHE BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN,
FIRST LATINA AND FIRST IMMIGRANT
TO BE ELECTED MAYOR TO THE CITY
OF ARVIN. WE MOURN THE LOSS OF A
FIERCE INDEPENDENT LEADER,
MOTHER, FRIEND AND AN EQUITY
ADVOCATE FOR HER COMMUNITY.
MAYOR TRUJILLO IS SURVIVED BY
HER THREE DAUGHTERS, OLIVIA,
VANESSA AND JANIE. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY
OF MAYOR OLIVIA TRUJILLO.
SENATOR GROVE, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
TOO RISE. YOU KNOW, GROWING UP
IN ARVIN AND LIVING WITH A
SINGLE MOM AND HAVING TO BE
AROUND FARMING FAMILIES, AND
ACTUALLY, MY MOM WORKED IN THE
FIELDS FOR A WHILE, AND SO DID I
DURING HIGH SCHOOL, AND THEN
HAVING OLIVIA TAKE THE POSITION
AS THE FIRST FEMALE ELECTED TO
THE MAYOR OF ARVIN WAS REALLY
INCREDIBLE. AND SHE WAS REALLY A
TRUE WARRIOR WARRIOR FOR THE
COMMUNITY, A WARRIOR FOR HER
CONSTITUENTS. THE ENTIRE CITY,
SHE KIND OF LINED THAT BOARD OUT
TO IF THEY WERE WRONG, SHE WOULD
JUST REALLY, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
TELL THEM HOW THE COW ATE THE
CABBAGE, BUT SHE DID. AND SHE
WAS STRONG ENOUGH TO STAND UP TO
THEM WHEN THEY NEEDED TO BE
STOOD UP TO AND STRONG ENOUGH
AND HUMBLE ENOUGH TO COLLABORATE
WHEN THEY NEED TO COLLABORATE TO
GET THE RIGHT THINGS DONE, MOST
OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW, BUT SHE IS
ALSO A GREAT FRIEND AND THE
DAUGHTER. HER DAUGHTER IS A
GREAT FRIEND OF OUR SENATE, OUR
OUR PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE,
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. EXCUSE
ME, MISS CONTRERAS. AND THEY
SPENT SOME TIME TOGETHER, AND IT
WAS REALLY HARD ON MISS
CONTRERAS THAT MISTER TRUJILLO
LOST HER LIFE, TO CANCER AS WELL
. SO IT'S A SMALL WORLD,
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
ILLNESSES LIKE CANCER. IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT COLOR YOUR
SKIN IS, WHO YOU ARE, HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU HAVE, OR HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU DON'T HAVE, IT'S A
DEVASTATING DISEASE, AND I THINK
IT BRINGS US ALL CLOSE TOGETHER
TO SEE THE REALITIES OF LIFE AND
TO ENJOY LIFE THE FULLEST, LIKE,
LIKE, MAYOR TRUJILLO DID. OLIVIA
WAS AN INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUAL,
AND I JUST WANT TO HONOR THE
SENATOR FROM KINGS COUNTY TO,
AND FRESNO FOR BRINGING THIS,
THIS, THIS ADJOURN IN MEMORY,
FORWARD, BECAUSE IT IS TRULY
HONORABLE TO BE ABLE TO JOIN HER
IN THIS BECAUSE TRUJILLO WAS A
VERY NICE AND VERY HONORABLE
INDIVIDUAL. THANK YOU, SENATOR
HURTADO. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
THE MAYOR'S STORY WITH US.
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO
THAT SO THAT SHE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE JOURNAL.
SENATOR WIENER, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ASK THAT
THE SENATE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
FORMER MTC METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ANNE
FLETCHER, WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH 1ST AND BEGAN HER CAREER
AT THE MTC AS AN INTERN IN 1982
AND JOINED THE STAFF AS A
PLANNER IN 1983. FOLLOWING A
MASTER'S DEGREE IN CITY PLANNING
FROM UC BERKELEY AND A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN URBAN
STUDIES FROM UCLA IN 2001, SHE
BECAME MTC'S FIRST DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
OPERATIONS AND DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR POLICY IN 2009,
ENABLING HER TO BE THE ONLY
PERSON TO HOLD EACH OF THESE
LEADERSHIP ROLES AND COORDINATED
THE BAY AREA'S RESPONSE TO THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT,
AND HELPED CREATE THE BAY AREA'S
WELFARE TO WORK PROGRAM AND
SHEPHERDED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE UNIVERSAL TRANSIT FARE
PAYMENT, NOW KNOWN AS CLIPPER,
IN THE BAY AREA. IN ADDITION TO
THE 511 TRAVELER INFORMATION
SERVICE, SHE ALSO SERVED AS THE
FIRST FEMALE CHAIR OF THE
INTELLIGENT TRANSPORTATION
SOCIETY OF AMERICA, AND WAS THE
FIRST RECIPIENT OF A LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM THE BAY
AREA CHAPTER OF WTF'S
INTERNATIONAL, FORMERLY KNOWN AS
WOMEN'S TRANSPORTATION SEMINAR,
WHICH PROMOTES THE ADVANCEMENT
OF WOMEN IN THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY AND WILL BE WARMLY
REMEMBERED BY ALL THE LIVES SHE
TOUCHED AND FOR HER DECADES OF
INSPIRING, INNOVATIVE AND
PRODUCTIVE WORK ON BEHALF OF ALL
BAY AREA RESIDENTS. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND PAUL,
AND HER SONS, MATT AND KEVIN,
AND AS A FORMER MTC
COMMISSIONER, SHE'S SOMEONE WHO
I WORKED WITH BACK WHEN I WAS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SHE WAS JUST
ONE OF THOSE ABSOLUTELY
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS WHERE
IT WASN'T ABOUT EGO, IT WAS
ABOUT GETTING THE JOB DONE. AND
SHE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING THE SENATE TODAY IN
THE MEMORY OF ANNE FLEMER.
SENATOR CORTESE, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I TO RISE, ON THIS
SAME REQUEST FOR ADJOURNMENT FOR
ANNE FLEMER. AND I SUSPECT THAT
HER FAMILY WILL BE LISTENING AT
SOME POINT TO THE PROCEEDINGS
HERE TODAY. AND WHAT I WANT TO
SAY, ON A PERSONAL NOTE IS I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE WITH
HER AS A MEMBER OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, AND I WAS COUNSELED,
IN A VERY GENEROUS MANNER BY
HER. BUT I THINK WHAT HER, HER
FAMILY, ESPECIALLY HER CHILDREN,
WOULD, WOULD WANT TO KNOW IS
THAT EACH AND EVERY DAY SHE
BROUGHT THEM TO WORK WITH HER.
SHE WAS A DEVOUT CATHOLIC AND
WAS RAISED, IF I REMEMBER RIGHT,
IN THE BELMONT AREA, WENT TO
CATHOLIC SCHOOLS AND HAVING HAD
A SIMILAR BACKGROUND MYSELF IN
TERMS OF UPBRINGING, I COULD
RECOGNIZE IN HER THIS GENEROSITY
OF SPIRIT, THIS SENSE OF CHARITY
, AND ENJOYED TALKING TO HER,
GIVEN THAT WE WERE ABOUT THE
SAME AGE AND HAD CHILDREN ABOUT
THE SAME AGE, ABOUT OUR
CHILDREN'S SUCCESSES AND, AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE BAY AREA AT
THE TIME, I WAS SHOCKED, JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS BACK, AT A
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND A BIG RECEPTION
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO FIND OUT,
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THAT
MOST OF THE STAFF HAD JUST COME
BACK, FROM ANNE'S MEMORIAL AND,
SHE WAS JUST REALLY GETTING TO
THE POINT, I THINK, IN TERMS OF
HER OWN LONGEVITY, HER OWN LIFE.
HAVING RETIRED FROM THE
COMMISSION A WHILE BACK TO
REALLY ENJOY HER RETIREMENT, SHE
WAS AT THAT AGE AND, YOU KNOW,
LIVING HERE IN THE BEAUTIFUL BAY
AREA, OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO HER
FAMILY, HER FRIENDS, AND TO ANNE
HERSELF THAT SHE DIDN'T GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENJOY THE FRUITS
OF HER LABOR MUCH LONGER. SHE
PASSED AWAY, MUCH, MUCH TOO
YOUNG, SO I JOIN IN THIS REQUEST
FOR THE ADJOURNMENT TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
DODD, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. YES.
ANOTHER FORMER COMMISSIONER FROM
THE METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND CHAIRMAN, I
REALLY APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S WORDS AND
ALSO FROM SAN JOSE, SIMPLY PUT,
ANNE FLEMER WAS THE BEST OF THE
BEST AT A TIME WHERE WOMEN
WEREN'T REALLY GETTING EXECUTIVE
POSITIONS, SHE ROSE TO ONE OF
THE HIGHEST LEVELS AT AT MTC,
AND AGAIN, SHE WAS JUST AN
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING PERSON. AND
THERE ARE SO MANY DISPARATE
GROUPS THAT ARE ALWAYS COMING
TO, YOU KNOW, TO MTC AND TO THE,
TO ALL THE REGIONAL BOARDS THAT
YOU ALL SERVED ON FROM TIME TO
TIME. AND SHE HAD THAT UNCANNY
ABILITY. FIRST OF ALL, SHE
WANTED TO BE OF SERVICE. SHE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW, GOT THEIR
SAY ON EVERY SINGLE ISSUE AND
THEIR POINT ACROSS. BUT IN THE
END, THE POLICIES THAT WE PASSED
AT MTC WERE FAR BETTER AS A
RESULT OF HER FINGERPRINTS BEING
ON THEM AND HER GREAT, GREAT
WORK. I TO, YOU KNOW, REQUEST
THIS ADJOURN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU,
SENATORS, FOR ALL THOSE KIND
WORDS. SENATOR WIENER, PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO THAT
WE MAY PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HER
IN THE JOURNAL. COLLEAGUES,
QUICK NOTE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
RUBIO, UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR, WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
LÀ HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE WELCOME
THEM. WELCOME TO THE SENATE. OUR
FINAL ITEM ON OUR AGENDA,
COLLEAGUES, IS COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR ARCHULETA
, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE WILL ROOM WILL MEET IN
ROOM 2200 AT ABOUT 305. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. SENATOR LYMAN,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK THANK
YOU. THE JOINT EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM 112 AT 3:00.
THANK YOU. SENATOR, IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR
MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, APRIL 11TH. WE'LL SEE
EVERYONE AT 9 A.M. ON THE 24TH.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT 9 A.M. HAVE A GREAT MONDAY.